amazon is back with its prime day sale  this summer and it's  earlier than it's ever been last year  prime day it was delayed until october  when online shopping was really the only  way we were able to shop with the  pandemic  now as more people go back to physical  stores amazon is hoping to entice  shoppers with new online offers this  year we have  more than 2 million deals for prime  members and that's more deals than we've  ever had before  for any prime day according to adobe  analytics about 60 percent of consumers  plan to shop  online on prime day and about 30 percent  expect to use money from their stimulus  checks  and it's not just amazon several  retailers like target and walmart  also offering sales right now to compete  if you need to buy anything  this is the time